good afternoon everyone good afternoon
I'm Marjorie given New York City
Commissioner for the United Nations
consular Corps and protocol part of the
mayor's office and the city's liaison
with foreign governments we're delighted
to be here at Columbia University and
greatly appreciate all of the support
and cooperation president Bollinger
senior executive vice president robert
Kasdan our conference collaborator and
monitor and moderator professor ester
Fuchs School of International and public
affairs and professor mayor feldburg
dean emeritus of the business school who
serves as as president of global
partners we also appreciate the support
of the New York Economic Development
Corporation led by Seth Pinsky our city
partner for this meeting SATs are you
here and see Seth here in all of us in
New York from the mayor's office EDC and
small business services are delighted to
welcome foreign delegates from Bangalore
Barcelona Berlin Bucharest Budapest
buenos aires Cape Town Geneva ho chi
minh city istanbul johannesburg karachi
Kiev with Lisbon Luxembourg leone
Montreal Munich Panama City stockholm
Tel Aviv and Tokyo everybody loves being
able to to read this list thank you to
GE for their generous underwriting this
morning you heard from GE CEO Jeff
Immelt we've enjoyed working with their
team Peter Faust Kevin Decker and Sarah
Cartmell who are here with us today and
thank you to all the panelists for
excellent presentations this conference
is organized by global partners the
private not-for-profit organization in
the mayor's office a major goal of the
organization is to create opportunities
for international learning in the
Bloomberg administration
global partners has organized nine
international summits on the most
important public policy issues facing
global cities for the first time this
summit is being webcast live at nyc.gov
/ global partners dramatically extending
our reach to all who are interested
around the globe who knows maybe our
summit will be trending on Twitter in
addition to the summit's global partners
created and maintains an online resource
bank of best practices from New York and
31 other global cities you can log on to
the website global partners / innovation
exchange another exciting initiative is
global partners jr. an online project
based education program this year 1900
middle school aged kids in 31 cities
around the globe are working together on
the same curriculum this year's topic is
the global marketplace they're learning
about becoming entrepreneurs venture
capitalists if you look at these
students final projects I bet you'll
find some great ideas these three
successful global partner programs the
online resource Bank the online
children's program and our summits
represent the Bloomberg administration
international approach engaging New York
City with dozens of foreign cities and
promoting innovative public policy
exchanges we're so pleased that the
World Bank has joined us as a co-sponsor
we all know that cities are on the front
lines affecting changes on issues from
climate change to job creation the world
bank recognizes this and is supporting
important programs in many developing
cities this year mayor bloomberg has
chair of the c40 cities climate
leadership group signed the memorandum
of understanding
with the world bank that will enable
global cities to access financing for
climate related projects to share some
of the World Bank's thinking on other
things cities can do we're delighted to
be joined by Sanjay prod on vice
president of the World Bank Institute
and a leading authority on strengthening
public institutions without good
governments in a way to stem corruption
the goal of our global partner summit
promoting business innovation and
entrepreneurship is near impossible
making Sanjay prod Hans work so critical
with to Harvard degrees and 25 years
experience in the World Bank Sanjay
speaks eloquently about combating
corruption and the transformative power
of access to information our focus is on
cities and the challenges and
opportunities created as a result of
urbanization it's in this context that
we've asked Sanjay to talk about how the
World Bank is working with cities
governments and their partners to create
opportunities for business development
it's an honor to welcome Sanjay Pradhan
here today
good afternoon thank you very much
Marjorie for that very thoughtful
introduction it's a real pleasure for me
to be here and I know I stand between
you and and delicious lunch but please
keep eating because i'm just going to
offer some food for thought it's
wonderful to be here to learn about the
most thriving cities are in the globe
today and to learn from many of you i'm
not going to repeat the entire list but
it is indeed quite enthralling for us to
listen to the experiences of many many
cities that we've already heard
barcelona's Stockholm Berlin
Johannesburg and so on but I want to
beat the whole the whole list again but
to me it is a tribute to the global
vision of Mayor Bloomberg that he has
convened right here in this platform the
foremost urban policymakers and
practitioners in perhaps what today is
the most cosmopolitan city of our time
New York along with Mayor Bloomberg's
leadership role in the c40 climate
change cities for climate change
leadership group this gathering when you
combine his leadership role in the c40
with this gathering it's really not only
underscores Mayor Bloomberg's commitment
to the city agenda but it really
positions him as a global leader who has
been underscoring repeatedly the pivotal
role that cities can play in building a
dynamic economy and a more resilient
society so with this backdrop you've
already heard today from very
inspiration I thought the morning
conversation was absolutely fantastic we
have heard from many inspirational
leaders from government from private
sector what I want to do here today is
share with you some thoughts from the
viewpoint of the World Bank an
international organization that is
working across countries and across
cities so I aim to give you not a
perspective of one city but a global
perspective
coming from our engagement from a number
of countries and number of cities and
what I'd like to do is to speak to you
about three questions the first question
is while we have been hearing about
individual cities from a global
perspective from an international
perspective how significant is the
phenomenon of urbanization today how
significant is the phenomenon of
urbanization for developing countries
for job creation that people have been
talking about for economic growth and
within this what is the role of
entrepreneurship and innovation in
fuelling that growth the second question
I'd like to talk about which is the
focus of this conference is what can
cities do to stimulate innovation and
entrepreneurship and the third is what
is the World Bank doing to support this
agenda for countries and cities so let's
first start turn to from a global
perspective what is the economic
significance of urbanization if we
aggregated across the cities that we've
been hearing about now it turns out that
once upon a time if you go back only a
few years ago the dominant focus of
development policy was on agriculture
and rural development that is still
important but what has become clear in
the last decade for sure is that
urbanization has become the defining
phenomenon of the 21st century I'll just
quote for you some statistics which are
staggering from a global perspective
near took nearly two billion new urban
residents will enter the world cities by
2030 and most of them from developing
countries so that's nearly two billion
new urban residents will enter urban
populations in South Asia and Africa
will double in 20 years emerging market
economies which will soon be
contributing fifty percent of GDP growth
globally most of them will be coming
from the cities and extra 320 310
million a new workforce working-age
people about thirty-five percent of the
global expand
shin of the workforce will crowd into
just 600 of the world's leading city so
that's an extra 310 million working-age
population that will crowd into just 600
leading cities so what is the
implication of all of these this
tremendous urbanization as a tremendous
phenomenon that we are viewing not just
in the developed countries but also in
the developing countries well the first
implication is that it will intensify
the challenge of job creation which has
become the top priority of every country
since the since the start of the global
economic crisis but it also tells you
that if the concentration of jobs is
going to be in cities then the
confluence of addressing the the job
creation challenge and the urbanization
challenge they have to go hand in hand
today in every newspaper in every forum
we are talking about the the imperative
of job creation what these statistics
demonstrate is the challenge of
confronting urbanization and job
creation must go hand in hand they must
go in tandem this also may makes it
clear that this is also clear a very
important for poverty reduction poverty
is no more a rural or underdeveloped
regional phenomenon poverty is
urbanizing in a number of countries you
see a very large concentration of the
poor now in urban areas and it's not
because cities are making people poor it
is because poor people are coming from
the villages looking for economic
opportunities in the cities and so let
me give you another statistic just to
illustrate that in Lagos Nigeria every
hour so this is the hour while we are
having this lunch every hour 11 new
residents are going to move from the
village from the villages to Lagos
looking for new opportunities so about
200 250 300 people a day that is
permanently residing coming to the city
so they are looking for jobs they are
looking for economic opportunities and
so the urbanization agenda is critical
for job promotion it is critical for for
poverty rate
action now if this is if these are the
potential of what urbanization can do
the fact is that urbanization and the
urban agenda is well placed to meeting
this challenge throughout history
urbanization and job economic growth
have gone in tandem so one global
evidence I want to share with you the
World Bank has a flagship presentation
which is called the world development
report we have a whole group of people
who will actually go on sabbatical not
to Colombia but something akin to that
and they actually distilled the global
cross-country evidence on a particular
topic in 2009 the world economic report
was on reshaping economic geography
which really focused on cities and three
of the most interesting conclusions of
that particular study was that one when
you look at cross-country evidence
aggregate agglomeration or concentration
of economic activity has always been
strongly associated with economic growth
second no advanced country no advanced
country has reached high levels of
advanced advanced levels of development
without urbanization so to achieve
economic progress you have to go through
cities and third large primary cities
are really gateways to the International
economy these things position cities in
a very powerful way and as we know from
New York as we know from several cities
represented here today really the urban
areas are becoming centers of innovation
entrepreneurship creativity growth and
culture professor edward glaeser from
Harvard who's right now World Bank
global fellow he says that cities
themselves have been humanity's greatest
invention with the potential to make all
of us richer smarter greener healthier
and happier of course it's the potential
because there are some cities which also
don't meet that potential but the
question is if cities have this promise
and if cities have this robust
relationship with economic growth one
question we should think about is what
is it about cities that makes them
driver of economic growth what is it
about cities as a phenomenon again going
back to the world development report
2009 it finds and you know the most
palpable reason why cities have such a
dominant effect is because they have
high population density and what we call
a clustering of economic activity so in
the world well Development Report 2009
we find that this density actually
enables more efficient service delivery
because it lower the lowers the costs of
public and private provision of services
per capita and this high density enables
you to attract investment in
infrastructure due to the large market
size that's in terms of infrastructure
and service delivery but if we look at
innovation and entrepreneurship what is
it about cities that makes it such an
engine of entrepreneurship and
innovation the reason is once again if
you think about the high population
density it means this much higher level
of economic and social interaction among
citizens in a concentrated area of
geography and that means there is a
vibrant market of ideas a vibrant market
of ideas that Spurs innovation and with
that spurring of innovations
entrepreneurs and business enterprises
pick them up so cities as clusters of
economic activities or clusters within
cities actually attract creative people
and link them to know how and to
supporting institutions business
institutions and so on there's a
virtuous cycle that's created because
successful firms attract suppliers and
service providers lawyers accountants
financial institutions and in turn spin
off other successful startups so the
case of Bangalore which is featured here
is a good example where successful firms
want to locate in Bangalore because they
have a large pool of skilled labor and
that large pool of skilled labor comes
to Bangalore because their large number
of firms so they can they can actually
the risks are managed so there is a
virtuous circle that's created the
resulting clustering that you
have actually means that cities have a
disproportionate disproportionate amount
of wealth that that's generated and
economic opportunities so in India for
instance i was quite struck to know that
the seven largest metropolitan areas
which account for only one point one
percent of the land actually have and
still have only nine percent of the
population they generate eighteen
percent of the national employment than
thirty percent of business services
again it shows you the power of cluster
e if you look at China if you look at
China you find that 70 over seventy
percent of urban exports over sixty
percent of the foreign capital is
concentrated in cities that are jet that
with the population of 2.5 million
people or more in this manner by
clustering economic activity cities
across geography and over a period of
time have been the forefront of economic
progress in fact lowly I don't know if
you know this but I i find the statistic
quite striking cities account for
seventy percent of global gdp so if
cities are this this vibrant hub of
growth what is the link to economic
creativity clearly we have seen that
economic creativity is a driver of
cities as engines of growth and when
entrepreneurs are in the cities they in
fact that entrepreneurship is spurred by
that concentration and there is recent
empirical evidence that entrepreneurship
and innovation is geographically
concentrated and we also have studies
that show that when you have an
abundance of small firms that's
positively related to future economic
future growth in employment so in
abundance of small firms that are
innovative small and medium enterprises
they can generate future economic growth
that again puts the focus squarely on
the subject of this conference which is
how do you spur innovation and
entrepreneurship in cities so if cities
can be this this powerful engine of
growth and entrepreneurship is important
that brings us to the second big
question
what after all Mayor Bloomberg began
with this what can cities do to
stimulate entrepreneurship and
innovation and here I want to
acknowledge that the focus of this
conference on stimulating
entrepreneurship is actually very
profoundly important as against
attracting existing investment from
existing firms the reason is if you
focus on entrepreneurship you're talking
about new firms new products new ways of
doing things and that is value addition
not just for the local government but
also for the national government so it's
a positive sum game as opposed to
attracting a beggar thy neighbor policy
if you will so this focus on
entrepreneurship is very important but
what can cities do to spur
entrepreneurship is not a
straightforward question there's no one
size fit all but let me just share with
you three broad answers that emerged
when you look at different countries
experience and you look at the
literature in this area the first view
is what i would call serendipity it
basically says that II cannot that
economic growth is largely driven by
serendipity and perhaps some
contribution from economic geography
that it happens because of chance so for
instance one study on urbanization and
entrepreneurship in the u.s. concluded
that the launch of the semiconductor
industry first by Fairchild and later by
Intel which helped jumpstart silicon
silicon valley was essentially
accidental now I'm not an expert on
Silicon Valley some of you may be but
there are other such instances that when
you look at local economic development
in what happened there's one conclusion
that comes it happened and that these
are vibrant clusters are a matter of
chance and geographic luck but if that's
the case obviously it doesn't have much
implication for policy this would
correspond to the discussion question we
had in the last session which it should
governments do nothing it just happens
but even adherence to the serendipity
view would acknowledge that even if
serendipity happens and you have a
clustering there is an important role
for government and for policy to sustain
strengthen and consolidate the
serendipity that has happened so
that leads you to if it's not just lace
a fair and you can just let it go what
is the other thing you can do and that
brings in the second view and the second
view is summarized very nicely for the
how many of you have seen Kevin
Costner's field of dreams have you seen
it ok so it's summarized by a very it's
a movie for those of you from different
countries the Hollywood movie by Kevin
Kevin Costner stars in it field of
dreams and basically he gets a calling a
vision to turn his I guess it was his
cornfield into a baseball baseball field
and it was a bit of a crazy idea but
actually he the tag line is if you build
it they will come and if you think of a
lot of answers we've been getting it
fits into that tag line if you build it
they will come and what this means the
equivalent of the broad of the baseball
and that baseball stadium analogy in the
case of cities and entrepreneurship is
that cities must make broad foundational
investments in the basics in local
education in infrastructure including
roads and Brownback broadband
connectivity and regulatory
simplification that Mayor Bloomberg also
talked about so this and here I just
wanted to share with you one thought
which I was struck in the morning
conversation was the emphasis that not
only Mayor Bloomberg but several people
put on the quality of life and and
that's quite important the the
investment in amenities and culture and
especially the point that the mayor made
which is that given that today
businesses can locate and its location
is becoming new it's almost location
neutral operation of businesses where
they actually choose to physically
locate the quality of life issue and the
investment in culture and the arts and
amenities is going to be important now
of course in many of our countries in
the countries in the developing
countries we are operating we are far
from this they are many cities are not
even providing the basic foundation so
you have poor services water and
sanitation health education and so on
you have weak physical infrastructure
and onerous local regulations which
back to earth Marjorie was saying
actually generate a lot of a lot of
opportunities for corruption but those
cities that have actually built it so
people have come they have found that
investing in some basic foundational
areas of government actually helps so to
give you an example in Egypt we are
observing gazelles which are smes that
have increased employment at twenty
percent annually over the last five
years and that's quite striking and they
have done this because there was a basic
investment made in three things employee
training quality certification and
simple thing as fuel up power
interruptions they have been the main
drivers of employment growth more
broadly the evidence we are seeing from
another study that was done of Egypt
Lebanon Saudi Arabia Yemen and Syria
that worker education and training are
strongly related to the innovation
potential at the firm level the other
dimension which comes up important in
developing countries is the availability
of land so there was a survey done of
entrepreneurs in India then they found
that fifty percent of the firm's found
that difficulties in obtaining the
desired industrial location was a
problematic issue the other dimension
that many of our cities are working on
is increasing the speed and reducing the
costs of doing business with generate
opportunities for corruption so just to
give you an example there's a large
variation across cities it takes five
days in Singapore to start a business 38
days in Manila in Bogota Colombia it
takes around 74 days to to get a
construction permit and build a
warehouse whereas in Manila it takes
hundred sixty nine days obviously these
are areas that cities like Manila have
to work on the other area which is
important is access to capital in Sri
Lanka the National Development Bank has
recently announced a 21 million dollar
facility to support SMEs so you know
some cities in the second view which is
the field of dreams caption build it as
you can come you can invest in education
you can invest in a regulatory
simplification and with these foundation
cities can indeed attract talent and
I spend but the question is will that be
sufficient and that leads to the third
and final view which is that it's it's
good to invest in in the basic
foundations but you actually need to
have aggressive proactive and targeted
interventions which actually attract and
if you think of the presentations that
we've heard this morning several of them
actually ventured into that field which
basically says beyond these general
foundational investments you actually
need more targeted aggressive activist
areas in the sphere of national economic
policy that has been called industrial
policy although some of the
presentations we heard are not targeting
specific areas not targeting particular
winners but generally a more aggressive
so examples of this are direct
government grants income tax credits for
angel investors state-sponsored venture
capital and in the area that we've heard
a lot today about which is incubator
facilities for startups and also an area
on coaching and mentoring for
entrepreneurs so these can help overcome
some of the startup costs and they are
important where you can do it right and
emphasize where you can do it right
because investor firms have to choose
where to locate and they will go to
places which are more attractive so
consider the issue of land and office
space obviously if it's a dynamic City
real estate prices are going to be high
but that's going to be prohibitive for a
startup company so well located and well
networked incubators can overcome this
barrier by providing low-cost office
space networking and mentoring services
the city of children is a very good
example they were losing employment and
opportunities because of the loss of
manufacturing and they created an
incubator near the still renowned
technical institutes and what was
interesting is they made these technical
institutes shareholders in this
incubation which gave them an incentive
to collaborate cities can also grow in
this area of proactive reaching out if
they actually help companies connect
globally Singapore is a very good
example singapore International Chamber
of Commerce connects its small
entrepreneurs to networks of ambassadors
and so on and there's the spring agency
in Singapore
which provides technical assistance to
SMEs in developing exports and financing
opportunities but the one caveat I
wanted to stress which goes back to the
generous introduction that Marjorie gave
for me is that when we are talking about
this third aspect of aggressively
proactively providing incentives for
entrepreneurs we have two very much keep
in mind the capability in checks and
balances in that country and society
that we are talking about because what
we find in many of our cities which are
not doing step two right where the
capabilities are weak and where
corruption is endemic giving a much more
proactive especially picking winners can
actually degenerate into rent-seeking
regimes rather than entrepreneurship
supporting regimes so I turn to the last
area which is what the World Bank is
doing in this area we you know when you
think of the World Bank what do you
think about most people think about you
that I don't want to ask you that
question but most people think about the
money we lend right but what's
interesting about the World Bank is we
actually have three roles and the money
we lend has becoming is becoming
increasingly less important than the
knowledge services that we provide
countries and cities want to know what
is working elsewhere and we have a third
role which is convening in partnerships
because we have a forum we have a
presence and we can connect various
people so we intend to marshal all these
three functions to help cities address
these challenges particularly given the
scale of the issues that i mentioned and
in this regard to help with this we have
created a new urban strategy the
architect of that strategy is right
there along with several colleagues who
are here abba joshi and it highlights
the social and economic linkages across
the system of cities in a country and it
identifies the trade-offs and sequencing
that you need to do between let's say
the growth the inclusion and
environmental agenda here in this forum
we are talking about one dimension but
cities have to balance the multiple
agendas as part of the strategy we have
building partnerships with the private
sector with government with with civil
society organizations to pursue p
to peer learning and that's why we are
here in addition to the partnership we
cherish with with the foundation with
Mayor Bloomberg and so on is is that the
need to foster peer-to-peer learning in
this regard we have created an
urbanization knowledge platform what
what it basically means is that we are
collecting global best practice from
different cities we're collecting the
expertise and the platform aims to
convene connect pro create and customize
knowledge that spread in multiple
centers in multiple cities to in in
service of the country the ball back
Institute which I direct facilitates
this cross-regional learning south south
south north and just to give you an
example we organize the learning journey
in July where real Rio which is as you
know going to be the host of the 2014
World Cup and the 2016 Summer Olympics
we had them go to different cities to
learn and they came here right here and
they met with the New York City economic
development cooperation and greatly
benefited from this knowledge in lending
in financial areas are urban portfolios
about 40 billion dollars at this point
is a very high demand for a range of
services which go from helping cities
deliver services better slum upgrading
brownfield development and revitalizing
decaying cities the other area we are
providing a lot of support on which is
directly germane to this conference is
we're being asked to support innovation
agenda in cities in a large way and just
to give you an example in Russia we're
developing policies to support
innovation at national state and local
levels in South Africa we are supporting
technology transfer and diffusion in
Kazakhstan we are working on financing
instruments for innovation in India and
Vietnam we are supporting if you will
bottom-up inclusive innovation for the
poor in areas like food security and
right now one of our teams is in South
Paulo where it's helping a design its
its future economic vocation and the
role of of innovation one of the things
as we work with city and state
governments is how do you promote bottom
innovation and our flagship program in
that area is info dev which has been
referred to today which started a decade
ago and directly has funded 400
incubators around the world I understand
the presentation we heard from Cape Town
is one of those incubators another
example we have and I was approached in
the lunch in the in the coffee yawa by a
student from Columbia very excited who
wants to set up a social
entrepreneurship venture in Mumbai in
India and he wanted to know how in fact
that would be supported one instrument
we have for this and and this was Esther
was talking about social
entrepreneurship we've created this
platform called the development
marketplace which is a competition it's
a global competition we usher around
specific challenges and it invites
social entrepreneurs to solve particular
challenges and we provide grant funding
and even mentoring and support so we
have done this since 1998 we have given
out 60 million dollars to entrepreneurs
I think about 1,200 entrepreneurs in 800
innovative projects so let me close I
think I've gone on long enough with the
present global economic crisis with this
call for jobs with this call for
economic opportunities if you think of
the scale and the place that
organization occupies today there is a
there's a very vital role that urban
agenda and cities can play in meeting
this this global economic challenge of
job creation and economic growth but in
addition as urbanization is taking place
at really we are at a historically
unique time where urbanization is on the
cusp of being truly that the phenomenon
of the 21st century we have one chance
to get this right for many countries and
so we must not fail the ideas that we
exchange today the learnings we are
doing can be very important for sparing
new ideas for sparring new partnerships
and I find in this space that it's the
multiple sources of knowledge that I
gathered in this conference that are
gathered in this in this room are those
the the real wealth that we have you
know in the context of the global
economic crisis and the rise
the g20 people talk about that we now
have multiple sources of growth because
China India bricks have emerged as
multiple source of growth equally
profound is that your multiple sources
of knowledge multiple nodes of knowledge
that are embedded particularly in cities
around the world and it's through
exchanges such as this that we can all
be better informed and by informing and
inspiring each other I believe we can
capitalize on the challenge of the
century which is the challenge of a
rapidly urbanizing global economy thank
you very much thank you I know Sanjay
prod on this is wonderful we have time
for a couple of questions so I mean it's
going to look out and look for some
hands so we can get this and we have
some mike circulating so just if you
have a couple of questions or you can
finish your dessert you can do both okay
we have a question in the back thank you
hi Oscar she will leave it to a little
more from the Regional Planning
Association I was fascinated by your
discussion of the number of days that it
takes businesses to start up in
different cities from the low in
Singapore to be appalling 174 days in
Manila but I wonder where American
cities right and in particular New York
how many days here thank you let's take
a couple more because he's going to
answer questions all at once so do we
have other questions let me just address
that so we do a flagship report which is
called doing business and doing business
the unit of analysis our nation states
and we actually if we actually look at
objective indicators to see how many
days it takes to start a business how
many takes to register I mean has
various dimensions and in that but
that's usually been at the nation state
although in the large countries and I
have colleagues here who can
no the the gentleman who can raise your
erasers and their his group actually
prepares these reports so for some of
the larger countries like Brazil in
their China we do go to the city level
because it doesn't make sense you you
actually need to aggregate at the city
level but I don't believe we have not
done anything at the at the not in the
u.s. we haven't done this in the US but
perhaps we can we can sort of think of
ways to to to take that problem we have
we have another question up front over
here I had a Kevin Kelly Deputy
Commissioner for small business services
do you have you found in your experience
that when you talk about an activist
approached policy or regulations from a
government perspective that the real
problem is in the policies or the
oversight themselves where there's not a
match with what needs to be done or is
it how they're implemented in the ways
in which the apparatus pond ssible for
that type of oversight or actually
fulfilling their mission yeah if i if i
take the analogy with what we've seen
happen at the national level the problem
has been in places where it hasn't
worked the problem has been in both
areas you know so there has been a
challenge I mean some of the activist
approaches that were mentioned today for
instance around let's say developing
incubators are connecting entrepreneurs
more proactively in other areas they
don't involve picking winners but one of
the problems we have had in terms of the
design of the policy the first part of
what you're saying has been in that
picking winners because in countries
where where there is endemic corruption
and patronage that picking winners
naturally leads you to a certain self
selection which itself or you may not
have the information and so on but then
you also have the problem of the of the
actual implementation in other cases so
we've had a combination of both that
doesn't mean it cannot be done and it
can be done where the capability is
strong and where checks and balances are
strong so the only thing is when you
work in the world by
in any area including this one and
especially this one what you naturally
evolve is a differentiated approach
where you can do certain things along
the lines of what we have heard today in
advanced cities and advanced countries
and you have to be talking about much
more of the level playing field and
doing just the just the basics in other
countries I like to ask a quick question
I know there are a lot of people out
here are very practical about the work
of the World Bank and would probably
like to know what the process is to
apply to be a place where the World Bank
and vests and works with them on
projects because these are I know very
exciting to a lot of the cities that are
here being represented today including
New York okay so the usual process of
the World Bank is as you know the
financial part of the World Bank is it's
a bank for for governments and so
ministries of Finance for instance are
our natural counterparts and we go
through a whole process in every country
where we decide through a participatory
process what the priorities in that
country would be and in some countries
the urban agenda is quite important
cities approach us directly but they
also approached their note their own
national governments so the practical
process is it takes place in our
interface with the with the government's
but it's a much more dynamic process
because you can have cities that are
actually quite engaged in getting
financial assistance they approach as we
approach our counterparts and so on
that's purely on the financial part of
it so if some of you are interested but
I should also say that we have
colleagues here from the World Bank so
there he cities here that want to engage
with us we have colleagues who you can
talk to in terms of how to get but the
financial assistance is just one part a
lot of what we are doing in terms of
knowledge exchanges don't have that same
protocol don't don't have the same
requirement and today that agenda is
growing much more rapidly than then than
even the financial part well I really
want to thank you so much
for being here today sunjai pride hun
from the World Bank this has been a
great pleasure in a wonderful way for us
to spend our lunch thank you so much for
your support and your remark